- Well, look at this. Hey, everybody.
So you paid for the whole seat,
you're only gonna need the edge.
My name is Brian Vecci.
I'm the field CTO at Varonis
and I've got 20 minutes
before you all go get drunk
to talk about beyond posture management.
I'm gonna talk about data security.
For those of you that don't know,
Varonis is a data security platform.
And I've been doing this
for close to 16 years now.
I was in IT and IT security before that.
And one of the things that I learned,
16 years in cybersecurity, is
that attackers don't break in,
they log in.
I think we all know this.
Nobody breaks into a
bank to steal the pens.
If somebody gets access
to your infrastructure,
compromises an identity,
compromises an API, owns a device,
they're going after data,
but they're doing it through identities.
88% of data breaches
involve some sort of stolen credentials.
The best and easiest, fastest and best way
to get in to your infrastructure
is to steal an identity.
What happens when that happens?
Somebody logs in with those credentials.
Then, they exploit the blast
radius, they move laterally.
In the cloud, that means going
to different infrastructure
or different applications.
They elevate their privileges,
ideally getting access
to an admin account.
They establish persistence,
creating new identities and new accounts,
but the goal is always to get access to
so that they can steal and encrypt data.
The kinds of things being in the wild
are Codefinger, ransomware, and AWS.
This doesn't exploit
any AWS vulnerability.
It exploits an identity to get access
to data in your AWS environment,
and then it's ransomware,
to get access to it, steal it,
encrypt it, and hold it for ransom.
How might attackers do that?
Well, we're seeing things
like infostealer malware in the wild,
people putting malware into game cracks
that they host in GitHub
that users then download,
and then, of course, their
identities are stolen.
If I can get access to your
credentials, to your identity,
I can use that to establish
persistence, move laterally,
and get access to and steal data.
It's really all about
data. I said it before.
But if I get access to an identity,
if I get access to an API,
if I own one of your devices,
I'm not just going to look
at configuration files.
I'm not just gonna explore.
Data is the target.
Data is what has value.
Nobody breaks into a
bank to steal the pen.
They are after money.
Your threat actors, the
attackers that you're trying
to defend against are after data.
And there's lots of
vectors that a threat actor
is going to use to get
access to those identities
that they then will use to access data,
whether it's a phishing attack
or a supply chain compromise.
We have advanced persistent
threats that we see
in almost every big
environment in the world.
The goal, of course, is
to get access to data.
Now, DSPM, data security
posture management,
CSPM, configuration posture
management, is not enough.
It is one set of controls,
one set of defenses,
but it's not enough to protect you.
It can't detect changes in authorization.
It can't detect lateral movement going
from one piece of structure,
like your AWS environment,
to another hyperscaler,
or from a SaaS platform,
like Salesforce, in your AWS environment.
It's not gonna detect abnormal behavior
because these tools don't look
at how identities actually access data.
And it's not gonna detect
any current active threats
or insider threats.
If somebody already has valid credentials,
then they start accessing something
that they've never looked at
before, how would you know?
They are not exploiting the controls
that DSPM and CSPM are
designed to help you fix.
Posture management is one
piece of the security puzzle.
If you think about how
an attacker behaves,
you need identity protection.
You need to look at all of the accounts,
internal and external, in
all of the applications
and in all of the infrastructure,
whether it's a global identity
or an application identity,
whether it's a user identity
or a machine identity.
You also need to monitor
and manage your data
and configuration security posture.
You need data centric-user
and entity behavior analytics.
That means is you need to watch
how all these identities behave
and you need to look at the
data that they're accessing
and you need a full set of forensics
so that you can come quickly
to a complete picture
about what happened.
If you're a CISO or if
you're in a security team,
you generally wanna do four things.
You wanna stop breaches, you
wanna avoid paying any fines,
you wanna stop having to hire people
or pay others to do all of this work,
and you wanna be able to
prove that you did it.
Where did we start? Where did we finish?
How are we implementing these controls?
And what does right look like?
How can we prove
that we're actually
protecting our environment?
Let's start with identity protection.
You need to protect against the
most used methods of attack.
88% of data breaches involve a stolen
or compromised identity.
That means you need to watch identities.
You need to know what right looks like,
which are our human, which
are our machine identities.
And you need to remove excess privileges.
A lot of us have been trying
to solve these problems
by using identity and access management,
but that is only one piece of the puzzle.
Imagine when somebody or
something authenticates,
what do they actually have access to?
At Varonis, we do data risk assessments
for our customers in
their AWS environments.
And what we find is up to 40% of the data
that they're trying to protect
is open to literally every single account
that can authenticate to the environment.
Think about that.
Imagine if 40% of the
money in your bank account
would be anybody that
could walk in the door.
How long would you keep that money?
So you need strong identity protection,
but you need to manage the blast
radius of those identities.
Ensure least privilege, remove exposure,
but you need to do that safely.
In security, one of the things
that gets us in trouble most
is when we're like a bull in a China shop.
If you start making changes
without understanding
what those identities have access to
and how they've been
accessing that information,
you run the risk of breaking
things as you fix them.
Using that telemetry,
watching how data is accessed
by who and by what with the context
of what data is sensitive and important,
where do we have credentials?
Where do we have sensitive information,
like PII or intellectual
property or source code?
Once you have all of that context,
you can enrich logging and behavior,
and then you get useful user
and entity behavior analytics.
You can minimize the time it takes
to detect and respond to a threat.
The easiest analogy here
is your credit card.
We use credit cards primarily or partly
because they are safe.
Your credit card company knows who you are
and where you live and where you travel.
My credit card company knows
that I'm in Las Vegas today
because I booked a flight
using my credit card.
My credit card company knows
the kinds of things I buy,
the amounts that I buy,
and when I tend to shop.
So when somebody uses my
number to buy gas in Montreal,
a place that I'm not currently,
and that's a pattern
that a threat actor uses
to test a credit card number,
they know instantly that's fraud.
If you watch your data and
you watch your identity
with the context of what the data is
and who the identities are,
which accounts are human,
which accounts are machine,
what they have access to,
who they work with, how
they normally behave,
when and where and on what data types,
it turns out you can
minimize how long it takes
to detect and respond to threats
by alerting on things
without a lot of noise.
And then you need a forensics layer.
You need to be able to quickly
and completely answer the
question, what happened?
I've been involved with a
lot of incident response,
over the last 15 years,
and one of the things that I've learned
is that when there is an
incident, an insider threat,
an APT, an advanced attack,
a global data breach,
like what happened with SolarWinds,
the first question that gets asked isn't
how do we fix this or how do we recover.
The first question that gets
asked is what data was touched?
Was anything stolen?
Do we have to tell our employees?
Do we have to tell our customers?
If we're a public company,
do we need to tell the SEC?
Was there anything
material that was stolen?
And how do we minimize the damage?
That's the first question
and the second question
and the third question that gets asked.
Ask yourselves, as security professionals,
how long would it take
to answer the question,
what data was touched?
And then, how did the
threat actor get there?
What identity was compromised?
What permissions were changed?
Were there privileges that were escalated?
Was there lateral movement?
Do I have a single pane of
glass that'll tell me exactly
how this all happened?
At Varonis, we've built
a data security platform
over the last 20 years to do exactly that.
Now, some of you might
be thinking, "20 years?
AWS didn't exist 20 years ago."
It's 'cause 20 years
ago, nobody could do this
on a single file system
in a single data center,
let alone, these days,
where all of the places
that your data lives.
It lives in files. It lives in databases.
It lives in all of the hyperscalers.
It lives in S3 buckets.
It lives in databases
that live in RDS or EC2.
It lives in your AWS environment,
but it also lives in
the other hyperscalers.
And for many of you,
it still lives in your
data centers on premises.
What Varonis is is a
data security platform
designed to give you observability
so you can find these problems,
classify data accurately, cross cloud,
and in hybrid environments,
classify data accurately
in structured, unstructured
SaaS application databases,
files, collaborative platforms.
We'll give you observability
to where that data is.
And observability isn't
just data classification.
It's not just what's sensitive.
It's who and what has access to it.
And to do that, you need to look
at all of the access
controls, the deep links,
the permissions on all
of these containers.
You need to look at all of the identities
and all of their entitlements,
and you need to combine
all of them together
so that you can answer the question,
what on earth does Brian have access to?
What does this account have access to?
Who has access to this
sensitive data in this S3 bucket
or this Salesforce record
or this file sitting inside
a virtualized file server?
Varonis unravels all of that for you
so you can find problems,
you can identify exposures,
you can map access, and
you can measure risk.
But finding problems isn't enough.
Findings fatigue is a real thing.
If I just give you a list
of the hundreds of thousands
or millions of problems
that you have to solve,
that's not a solution.
Who among us has the people to go respond
to hundreds of thousands
of help desk tickets
or service tickets to go
fix all of these problems?
So Varonis takes all of this telemetry,
including all of the behavior information.
How is this data being
accessed by who and what?
How are these identities
authenticating and from where?
How is data flowing between
all of our infrastructure?
We use all that telemetry
to build automation.
And it's automation that
can be deployed safely.
If I'm gonna remove a
permission or fix an exposure,
I better know exactly what
might break when I do that,
so that, when I make
changes, I can do it safely.
And that's exactly what Varonis does.
We're watching how all of this data
is being used by who and what,
so when you apply
policies, you do it safely.
You can be surgical, but it's automatic.
So you can reduce risk
without breaking anything
and without requiring a lot of effort.
And because we have the
telemetry in the context
of what data is used by who and what,
from which devices and which services.
In all of the places that
Varonis provides visibility,
we give you useful user
entity behavior analytics
without a lot of noise.
We generate a very small alerts
that have a lot of context
about why there's a threat
that you need to respond to.
You can lock down your AWS IDM
so you can ensure that identities
are properly configured,
that your infrastructure's
properly configured,
and these identities only have access
to what they're supposed to.
You can enforce these privilege,
do it automatically
without breaking anything.
You can detect abnormal
behavior by watching
how all of the data in
your environment is used
with the context of what is sensitive.
Not just sensitive data,
but sensitive identities.
Which identities are human?
Which identities are machines?
Which identities are administrators,
whether you know it or not?
What are they accessing?
How are they accessing it?
What's normal, so that
you know what's abnormal.
Without a lot of noise, you
can minimize the time to detect
and time to respond to threats
and you can fix the problems
that you will identify.
The number of times I've
heard from hospitals and banks
and manufacturing companies
and software companies are,
"We know we have risks.
We just don't have the
people to solve them.
We know that there are
problems out there."
Varonis will show them to you
and then give you the
ability to automate policies
to fix the problems that we
find but to do it safely.
I used to ask security teams and CISOs,
"What keeps you up at night?"
I stopped asking that question
because what you wanna hear
is something really interesting.
What keeps me up at night
is nation-state actors.
What keeps me up at night is ransomware.
What keeps me up at night
are insider threats.
I stopped asking the question
because smart people
always answer the same way,
"It's not the problems that I know about,
it's the problems that
I don't know about."
Because Varonis looks at everything.
We don't use data sampling
or predictive scanning.
We will scan everything and
show you where you have gaps
and then we'll give you the automation
to find and fix those
problems automatically.
So you can go from, "I don't
know what I don't know"
to, "I do know my problems
and I have fixed them
and I can prove it and I
didn't break anything."
And you can do it extremely quickly.
We integrate with the AWS Security Hub.
We take signals and telemetry and analysis
and threats and alerts.
We import them and give
you additional context.
So we enrich the views that
you get from the Security Hub.
We enrich the telemetry streams
that you get from the AWS CloudTrail.
We add additional information
and context to the CloudTrail
so it's more useful and
it's a better set of signals
to detect and respond to
threats and to apply automation.
We enrich the IAM Identity Center
by giving context about data access
and where and how entitlements are applied
and what kinds of sensitive
data are available
to which identities.
And we enrich the AWS GuardDuty
with data-centric threat detection.
Everything that I've
just shown you integrates
with your AWS security stack.
We make the AWS security
controls and tools
that you have more valuable
and we make it easier to prove
that you're implementing
controls and we do it safely.
We secure data across your AWS ecosystem,
whether they're SaaS
applications and platforms,
like Salesforce and GitHub,
that are integrated with
your AWS environment,
or data stores that are living inside AWS,
like Snowflake and Databricks.
And the databases that are sitting in RDS
are virtualized in EC2,
let alone all of the data
that's sitting inside S3 environments.
We'll secure this data across cloud.
We give you a single pane of glass
and a single set of
policies and automations
that you can apply quickly,
easily, and safely.
If you would like to learn
more, and I know you would,
'cause if you sat here this long
while there's free beer over there,
that means you wanna learn more.
If you'd like to see how this works,
if you'd like to see a demo,
either tonight or maybe tomorrow,
either give us a call or
come over to our booth.
We're booth number, oh, there's
no booth number on here.
It's four something. It's
right along the back wall.
Varonis.
It's a data security platform
that will help you find
problems, automatically fix them,
automatically detect
and respond to threats.
And the way we start is
we do a risk assessment.
This takes 15 to 20 minutes
to plug into your AWS environment.
We'll look at the other hyperscalers.
We'll look at on-premises data.
We'll look at files.
We'll look at databases.
We'll plug into your
Salesforce environment.
We'll plug into your GitHub environment.
And very quickly, on day
one, you will see results.
Within a week, you'll see real risks.
And within a couple of weeks,
we will show you a real
plan to reduce them.
But even if you do nothing else,
I can guarantee you we're
gonna show you things
that you didn't know about your data.
The whole reason, the
whole goal of cybersecurity
is to protect data.
We make it easy. We'll do it cross-cloud.
We'll do it accurately and
we'll do it automatically.
And if you don't believe
me, well, come and try it.
I'll take the Pepsi Challenge
against any other tools
or processes that you have in place.
I've been doing this for a long time.
I've seen people struggle.
I've seen people do a little
bit with a lot of people.
We'll help you do a lot
with just a little bit.
I'm gonna end a little bit early
'cause it looks like
you guys all wanna go.
Enjoy the rest of the show
and enjoy your time in Vegas.
My name is Brian.
I've got a flight to
catch in about 40 minutes,
so I'm gonna run upstairs
and catch an Uber.
I really appreciate your time.
I hope you come over and learn some more.
Thank you all so much.
There it is, booth 430.